[Music]
good evening
and welcome to a special inside the
issues
edition of tucker carlson tonight i'm
mark stein in fotucker
who will be dropping by a little later
inside the issues in a land beyond law
we have breaking news tony podesta
the democrat lobbyist whose brother john
podesta was the hillary clinton campaign
chair
who got hacked because his password was
password
with a zero where the o should be anyway
tony podesta
doesn't need to be hacked by hostile
foreign entities because he's already
working for them he's just signed on to
be a lobbyist
for huawei the world's largest
manufacturer
of telecommunications equipment and the
second biggest
maker of smartphones bigger than the far
more famous apple
hey remember what they told us 20 years
ago
china was going to be making all the
crappy knickknacks and these colors
don't
run t-shirts and your coffee mugs and
sneakers and cheapo office furniture
and instead america would be the
knowledge economy somehow
china wound up with all the knowledge
too and via huawei
it's been shipping the knowledge to the
likes of iran
which is why its business activities are
restricted to one degree or another
by the us and other governments but
notwithstanding u.s government sanctions
huawei is still respectable enough to
attract hot shot democrat players
close to joe biden such as tony pader no
sorry stop stop stop
i can't go on with this it's the weekend
and the soul needs cleansing it does a
fellow good to raise his eyes from the
dank
sewer of political corruption among a
diseased and decadent pseudo-elite of
third-rate grifters
selling out their country and
contemplate
instead the pure
unsolid
pristine translucent beauty
of fine art at its finest
oh that orchestra is rehearsing in the
next room again
yes this month
the manhattan art world has been wrapped
by the news that the acclaimed artist
hunter biden the botticelli of bagman
the pizarro of politburo suck-ups
has painted a self-portrait it shows
hunter after he
accidentally stuck his crack pipe in his
ear
oh no sorry that's van gogh cutting off
is here
now this new self portrait shows hunter
biden after swinging by the department
of justice and
accidentally smoking the ever more
imminent
durham report oh my mistake no that's
francis bacon self-portrait ah here we
are stan well back
self-portrait by hunter biden
hmm and if you're saying
hey wait a minute i stayed at that
corner suite at the airport marriott
just last month you're missing the point
what makes it a self-portrait of hunter
biden is that if you
peer very carefully at the left-hand
horizon you can just make out
saki in the press room explaining why
this sudden boom in hunter biden art it
now accounts for i believe
three percent of gdp it's all
strictly on the up and up
well this showing that was uh that
you're referencing was previously
public uh he's not going to have any
conversations related to
the selling of art that will be left to
the gallerist
we believe this is a reasonable system
that has been established that allows
for hunter biden to work in his
profession
within appropriate safeguards so he's
not going to discuss anything related to
the selling of art
and i would reiterate that the gallerist
will be the only person who handles
transactions or conversations
in that vein and will reject any offer
that is out of the ordinary
wouldn't it be more transparent to just
release the names of the buyers so that
everyone would know who purchased this
art and how much they paid
well we don't we won't know who the
buyers are hunter biden won't know who
the buyers are but we won't know who
they are
so there's no scenario where they could
provide influence
uh-huh here's how it works uh inferior
gallery
is what they call in american law a
public accommodation
anyone can walk in art lovers passing
tourists
process servers delivering subpoenas
from hunter biden's baby mamas
foot pads and nerdy wells stunned to
discover
that the hunter biden exhibition is the
only store in new york
where everything is so highly priced it
falls above the upper limit of the new
please feel free to loot and steal
without any consequences law
anyone can walk in and look at the
paintings even republicans
but if you try to buy them you find
they've already sold at the private view
which is invitation only and which the
artist if he's living
which hunter on his more lucid days just
about is
uh is expected to attend and mingle with
the invitees
aesthetically sensitive lobbyists
generals of the chinese people's army
ukrainian oligarchs the wife
of the former mayor of moscow somali
warlords and
other celebrated art collectors when
you're a living artist making half
a million bucks per quote artwork
you know who your buyers are and what do
you know
that's just how it is with hunter former
obama ethics honcho no right winger no
fan of this show walter
schaub quote hunter biden will meet with
prospective buyers of his absurdly
overpriced
presidency profiting art good
grief who are these prospective buyers
of hunter biden's fabulous paintings
well the manhattan art world is abuzz
with rumors
mary ping the great aunt of chairman xi
jinping and a familiar figure at
sotheby's auctions is a famous collector
of
still lives vases of flowers bowls of
fruit attractively arranged mounds of
dead uyghurs
but she's thinking of switching to
bidens uh slobodan
bogamill barisma the third cousin twice
removed
of the billionaire ukrainian deputy
assistant minister of energy
controls forty percent of the region's
oils
but now says there's more money in
watercolors
massive pipeliner the kazakh supermodel
who
works with a similar blowpipe to hunter
she sucks in all the gas in central asia
and thanks to a new deal approved by joe
biden blows it all the way over to
germany
and then of course fang fang the crack
chinese agent who penetrated democrat
presidential candidate eric shagwell is
said to be looking for an attractive
pastoral landscape to hang on the
ceiling
these guys don't know much about art but
they know what they like
and what they like is a biden family
whose main
creative energies go into devising new
and ever
more artful ways to be bought this is a
way better racket than the clinton
foundation
under the clinton model a saudi prince
or a sudanese machete magnet
had to pay 2 million bucks and sit
through a speech by chelsea on diarrhea
in africa
hunter is to art as chelsea is to
diarrhea speeches but at least you can
sell the frame for 12 bucks
and use the picture as a scarecrow
meanwhile
rival new york gallery owners are urging
joe biden to cease eating tapioca
and watching matlock in the white house
basement because he could easily
double hunter's prices by offering
himself up
as a surrealist performance art do you
dig those q and on theories
joe's taking them mainstream we are not
defunding the police are there people
who
in the democratic party are the people
in the republican party do you think
we're sucking the blood out of kids
i i'm not sure
corn pop liked to suck the blood out of
kids
they'd be on the diving board admiring
my leg hair
and he'd rear up in his esther williams
bathing cap had to take the tire on to
him come on man
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else